Yes, we are now joined by our good friend,
comedian Jay Pharoah.
Jay in the building. What up, what up, what
up? What's going on? Campaigning.
What's happening? What's happening?
So now, Jay, your insights into the
celebrity mind are always spot on.
Yes, yes they are. And since we said our
piece about 2023, we'd love to get your
unique takes on some of the biggest stories
of the year. Jay. How
do you think Will Smith reacted to Jada's
book? Yeah, well, you know, like there's
clearly, you know, other news out there
that's like happening.
You know, there's like clearly, you know.
Very clearly. Other things like going on like
Diddy is like out there.
Yeah. Like that man went from Diddy to Diddy
do it. Yeah he did.
Yeah. Yeah.
Bad marriage for life okay.
Woo. Check it out.
It's pretty insane I mean it's really insane.
Yeah okay. Here's another one.
How do you think Jay-Z felt about Beyonce's
tour taking over the world?
It was cool. But, uh, you know, Taylor's
numbers are insane.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. You know, like, I support her,
you know, I'll be like, here, you'll get
there, you know? But she's, you know, she's
she's killing it. You know, I go on the road
as well, right.
Okay.
Good, good. That's nice.
Jay-z. That's nice for you.
It's good, it's great.
It's great to.
Sometimes be positive, right?
Yeah, yeah. That's good.
Yeah. I'm glad you came. At the time, a lot
of spit came out there.
Sorry. Yeah. That's okay.
I don't got Covid. It's fine.
No.
You're fine. Uh, how about this one?
Give us a Stephen A Smith.
Like, give us his final take on this amazing
year in sports.
Well, let me just say this.
This has to be one of the worst years in
sports ever. The worst years in
entertainment we've ever we've ever dealt
with. And let me tell you why.
Let me tell you why, Kevin. You want to know
why Kevin asked me? Why say why, Stephen?
Why, why why, Stephen?
Because Shannon.
Sharpe.
It usually has that effect.
It shocks people. My voice is very shocking.
That's what it is. Because Shannon Sharpe
called me Skip Bayless, a white man, 175
times on national television.
It's just ridiculous.
That is. You.
give us some Shannon. Give us a little bit of
Shannon.
I can do. Shannon. Hey, uh, listen, Skip.
All right?
All right, let's just move on to the next
thing. I mean, goodness gracious.
Bill, listen with a m. Listen.
How many? I mean, how good is this?
It's like they're right here in the room.
Now, of course, the most exciting news of the
year was the announcement that Kevin Hart
will be getting his Mark Twain Prize next
year. That's right.
Come on, put it together.
Thank you. Man, why don't you give us a
little bit of Kevin's first reactions when
he found out he was getting the Mark Twain?
Ah, well. God damn.
Ah. Wow.
My stand up show.
My show.
The show that I do.
Uh huh. The show that I do is only
second to the birth of Jesus.
I sware to god, I swear, I swear.
That's the biggest around. That's what.
Listen, it's a wrap. It's a wrap.
Yeah. That's ridiculous.
Say, Philadelphia. Philadelphia.